c'est un petit fruit encore méconnu
originaires d'europe et d'asie la baie
d'argousier en fait il reste tant à
découvrir sur ce super aliments qu'un
producteur prend part à un projet de
recherche pour valoriser tous les
résidus de ce petit fruit mais encore
faut-il franchir d'abord une première
étape
la cueillette voici un verger pour le
moins coloré
de près la couleur éclatante des grades
de fruits ne trompent pas
nous sommes dans une plantation
d'argousier un arbuste qui produit la
recours
pour robert paiera tout a débuté il y à
12 fois qu'on a commencé notre verger
avec une centaine de pièces qu'on a fait
des boutures avec les moues du titre a
donc été une aventure assez longue avant
de remise
à l'automne lorsque les branches croule
sous le poids des baies robert père a
fort à faire pour récolter les fruits de
cette culture méconnue un possible de
cueillir les baies d'argousier
directement dans l'arbre
[Musique]
les très longues épines font partie des
embûches qui se dressent sur le chemin
des cueilleurs une fois les branches
récolté l'épreuve n'est pas terminée
les fruits seront accessibles beaucoup
plus tard dans le processus
on est capable dans le livre fut
seulement quand ils sont conduits on
n'est pas d'enlever les flux ils le
paient donc eu de la chance oui tout
solidement sur sur la brasse on les met
dans des contenants de bois ajouré pour
incapable de combler autre handicap
surtout pour la commercialisation
le fruit est très acide au niveau
gastronomique elle et l'engouement est
ce que des chefs qui commence à cuisiner
la rouzique pendant un bon cuisinier je
vous dirais la lose it assez difficiles
sa pole goût terrible si tu dis c'est un
goût astringent amer par contre pour
acidulées un plot dabouz espère alors
pourquoi je donne est en mal parce que
les baies d'argousier sont ce qu'on
appelle un super aliments leur teneur en
antioxydants est très élevé plus que la
camry zh le bleuet ou la canneberge
sans compter qu'elles contiennent des
oméga 3 6 7 et 9 et 30 fois plus de
vitamine c que le range
faut pas trop en bras parce que ça
l'excès de la dose à me tamin c'est le
430% de vitamine c dans notre
cultivables dans une cuillère la table
de ceux de lens à 25 millilitres vont
être la dose à peu près 100 % de la
vitamine c il recommandé c'est la seule
klein dans le végétal du post si sienna
mérites d'une heure tu as de lomé
gaussel l'argousier cultivé depuis des
siècles en europe pour ses propriétés
médicinales la plante était largement
utilisé dans la grèce antique l'empiré
romain en mongolie et en russie
aujourd'hui c'est en chine qu'on
retrouve les plus grandes superficies de
cultures d'argousier au monde au québec
l'argousier à tout d'abord été plantés
comme arbuste ornemental avant d'être
exploitées pour ses propriétés
thérapeutiques
[Musique]
trois mois après avoir été entreposés
dans le congélateur les branches
d'arbres vous y sont prêts
si certains producteurs se contente de
les secouer à la main pour détacher les
petites baies congelés monsieur paiera
lui a imaginé une façon plus pratique
d'en venir à bout
il a fait l'acquisition d'une machine
habituellement destiné à un tout autre
usage
comment cette idée là se fera sur
youtube
regardez
et puis bon poulet je me suis dit les
bras jalousie sont congelés l'île fut
son congé sur une salade des ça peut pas
faire totalement fonctionné
effectivement ça fonctionne bien le
contenu qui en ressort est ensuite
tamisée et envoyé dans un nettoyeur à
grains pour séparer les feuilles des
fluides avec les feuilles le producteur
fait de la tisane encore là monsieur
perrin a mis son imagination à profit ce
monsieur n'à pas ceux qui ceux qui
travaillent la pâte d'utiliser cette
machine non pour enlever les feuilles
tombent à celle de l'âge des photos de
peuples tout simplement lever les
batteurs qui avaient et ont toujours les
patates de l'époque ça enlève les
feuilles ça va très très très bien cet
article mais quand vient le temps de
faire le jus d'argousier qui est le
produit vedette de l'entreprise
c'est le retour à la méthode artisanale
les bessons passer manuellement à
l'extracteur
à la longue robert perras a eu une
intuition les résidus de l'extraction
il pourrait peut-être en tirer quelque
chose c'est la raison pour laquelle il
fait maintenant c'est chez les pépins
d'argousier ainsi que la pulpe du petit
fruit
ils les envoient ensuite en laboratoire
ou des chercheurs en analyse les
propriétés service un peu les fruits
c'est comme des modes
donc il ya des modes il ya eu le bleu
est pisté canneberges et puis maintenant
c'est rendu l'argousier ainsi que tous
ces petits fruits seront riches dans les
familles antioxydants donc
donc c'est sûr qu'un potentiel à
développer là dans la chaire de
recherche industrielle en extractible
agroforestier a pour mission de trouver
des débouchés aux matières agro
forestières en particulier les écorces
de bois et les petits fruits la
polyvalence de l'argousier emballe le
chercheur yacine bomgar en général si
vous prenez le bleu est bon on pouvait
faire un peu de vous allez faire du jeu
un extrait mais après le pulpe est
tellement fin que vous n'avez pas grand
chose à en tirer ce dirait
le laboratoire teste présentement les
possibilités offertes par la pulpe
d'argousier sécher après un passage de
quelques heures dans cet appareil on
extrait une matière grasse de l'huile de
pulpe qui contient beaucoup d'hommes et
gas est un acide gras
[Musique]
les chercheurs ont également réussi à
extraire de l'huile de la poudre sécher
de pépin un produit qui est riche en
oméga 3 et 6 les acides gras bénéfique
pour la santé
[Musique]
si vous prenez leur gosier
vous allez avoir un jus deux villes à
partir de pulpe et t pain et à la fin le
résidu finale nous on pense qu'il a une
application pour l'alimentation animale
parce qu'ils sont riches en fibres et
protéines vous voyez c'est un problème
c'est multi produits qu'on
helsinn bomgar et robert erra ont
d'autres projets pour les sous-produits
de l'argousier il songe maintenant à
élaborer des produits cosmétiques ainsi
que des nutraceutiques des aliments qui
ont un effet bénéfique pour la santé
et pourquoi pas obtenir la bénédiction
de santé canada le jus est à mon avis va
être facilement molobi parce qu'il ya
une monographie sur vitamine c qui est
déjà publiée par son thé canada dans
quelqu'un pourrait faire je n'en mois un
jus personnes produits sont naturels
avec de l'argot gilles robert peyrat qui
a investi des dizaines de milliers de
dollars dans la chaire de recherche
espère qu'au bout du processus
il pourra faire la promotion des
multiples bénéfices qu'ils prêtent à
l'argousier on a énormément de
témoignages de gens qui ont des
problèmes de putsch guérissent avec à
louviers ou d'énergie beaucoup de jeunes
futurs patrick duval sont réellement
c'est ses formes à l'exceptionnel c'est
la raison pour laquelle on fait partie
d'une chaîne de recherche besoin c'est
des scientifiques sait déjà qu'ils sont
habilités à dire des choses c'est ça
qu'on veut prouver simplement sommet
mais d'ici là il ya encore beaucoup de
travail à faire lentement mais sûrement
comme dit souvent c'est passionnant mais
pas payer mais c'est passionnant très
passionnant
[Musique]